what's up
hey rach how's it going can you hear me
good good i got you what can i do for
you tonight
yeah i want to ask you something rich
you've said that um
the biological purpose of a man is to
spread his seed
but how does he do that outside of
marriage and avoid
legal pitfalls
how does he do that outside of marriage
and avoid legal pitfalls what are you
talking about knocking up like a
mistress or something
yeah and the woman can
uh you know have wages garnished and
i'm not sure if you're asking to to like
spread your seed in such a way that your
wife's cool with it are you doing this
covertly behind her back
well you i think you've discouraged men
from getting married
yeah marriage is not a good deal for men
but i understand that there's a lot of
guys that have like you know convictions
towards it or cultural issues towards it
so like are you saying that you want to
get married or that or that you don't
want to get married but you want to have
kids
i do want to have kids but
um
i mean you know what
okay so i mean the question is how do
you minimize the risk okay yeah okay
okay yeah so i got you um so i did a
cast in the last couple weeks i don't
know if you saw it on the playlist but
there was uh two guys well there's
the main guy from the parenting center
did you see that one
and he broke down all the states okay so
you want to go back to that the first
thing that you want to do is you want to
live somewhere where default shared
parenting is already in place
because
if you're going to have kids you know
regardless of whether or not you get
married or not the state is probably
going to see it as a marriage so if you
live anywhere in canada you know for
example for the most part with the
exception of quebec the laws over there
are slightly different um where do you
live by the way
west coast
west coast of canada or the us
you know the united states very little
so
okay so every state on the west coast
sucks for having kids
um you're going to want to move
somewhere like arizona i think uh
kentucky or tennessee one of those two
states was the best one on the list but
if you watch that podcast he breaks down
the main state so first things first is
you want to move to a place where you've
got default shared custody because half
the time that the relationship's not
going to work out and that just kind of
deals with you having a fight over
getting access to the kids and being
able to share parenting responsibilities
and her not being able to steal the kids
or make unilateral decisions around
where she's going to live or name
changes or medical procedures or any of
those things uh kentucky was the number
one thanks moff um so you want to live
in a place where you don't have to deal
with that the only thing that you've got
to contend with then is dealing with the
matrimonial assets so again whether
you're married or not does it matter
you're going to you know you're going to
create assets together at some point in
that state that you live in they're
going to deem that you're married and
that you're going to have to divide up
the assets right so that's really the
only thing you have to deal with
then you don't want any red flags if you
can avoid them and you ideally want as
many green flags i did a video last week
on green flags uh my red flag chapter is
available for free on my email list
if you guys are newer to the channel let
me put the banner up on the bottom there
so down over here
if you go to
entrepreneursandcars.comredashflags
you can get that chapter for free it's
also in my book it's just a chapter that
i took out of the book to
let you guys opt into the list
you don't want any red flags
if if you make concessions and let's say
you deal with a violent woman or you
deal with a woman that's got daddy
issues there's two red flags right there
that are pretty bad the chances of you
running into problems with custody being
able to raise your kids properly having
influence in their lives is going to go
up dramatically right so those would be
the main things is live somewhere where
it's shared custody if things go
sideways if you make a lot more money
than she does have a prenup but keep in
mind prenups are only good for a short
period of time so if you're you know
together for 10 15 years it's not gonna
be worth anything it'll be like toilet
paper but if it's only like two or three
years after you break up it's going to
be useful
no red flags and as many green flags as
possible
make sense
yeah but just to be clear rich
you wouldn't recommend that men
you know have children propagate
outside of marriage because that's that
has its own problems i mean your assets
are probably aren't going to get seized
but you can still have your wages
garnished uh the kids could end up
living with a single mother
well you're going to avoid the risk
exposure to that dramatically like
you're going to lower the risk exposure
if you live somewhere like kentucky
right
and you vet for red flags you don't deal
with a check that's got a bunch of red
flags and she and she's got a lot of
green flags right the chance that you
run into it doesn't matter if you're
married or not like marriage has nothing
to do with raising kids that's just a
party for women
you see what i'm saying
or if you have cultural like affinity
you know towards it if your family wants
it or if you're all about it sort of
thing fine okay whatever but
you can live in a way that looks like
marriage and the government's gonna call
it a marriage right so after a certain
period of time because a common law
you know like here i think it's two or
three years you know in canada so if you
live with a check for two or three years
you're basically common law and family
law now applies to you know the
i'm just calling them matrimonial assets
but whatever assets you know you have
together if you gotta un untie the knot
you're gonna have to give her half your
if you got more
right
but you want me to give you the cheat
codes yeah but i mean like you want me
to give you the cheat codes all this
like solve the problem right now you
can't do that you're gonna have to read
the red flag chapter have you read it
no i do have the book on kindle though
okay so
read the red flag chapter watch the
podcast i did last week on the green
flags and look at the podcast prior to
that on the uh states that you should
live in where shared custody is default
and you've got most of the information
that you need right there
all right thank you for the advice all
right man thanks
you